working in a morgue requires some
specific skills you need to be
comfortable being around the dad you
need to have a great attention to detail
and you better not be squeamish you'll
be getting up close and personal with
some gruesome specimens but for those
who find themselves in a specific morgue
under the supervision of the scp
foundation they'll need to have some
extra specific skills if they hope to
get out alive
in the basement of an old hospital in
great britain there was a morgue it
appeared like any other until the 1980s
with a busy hospital staff coming in and
out to investigate causes of death and
perform autopsies reporting anything
unique to the doctors upstairs but soon
the morgue and the hospital around it
began to get a reputation people
whispered that something wasn't right in
the morgue that there were supernatural
dealings afoot and soon
they were proven right because what's
dead in
scp-022 doesn't always stay dead the
foundation soon stepped in and
quarantined the morgue condemning the
building an investigation didn't find
any cause for the unpredictable and
dangerous phenomena but the foundation
was able to track the pattern of
reanimations and did happen upon the
following the morgue is filled with body
storage drawers and at random times the
spontaneous opening of one or several of
them will occur and despite the fact
that the morgue has been out of
operation for quite a long while
whenever a drawer opens there is a body
laying inside under a sheet every time
and after six minutes of being opened
the body will wake up when awake these
reanimated corpses have exactly one
mission to get out of the morgue by any
means necessary if the corpse is
relatively intact it will leap off the
table and charge at the door and
anything else in its way while no
specimen has ever been safely captured
for testing their base strength seems to
be far stronger than any normal human no
evidence of what gives them this power
has been found but they are absolutely
formidable and very hard to stop and to
add to the difficulty they're even
harder to kill a second time around
while all evidence indicates that these
are reanimated humans they do not seem
to be limited by the same physical
effects of damage those who have tried
to stop these undead beings from getting
to the door have found this out the hard
way these cadavers seem to be immune to
just about any form of impairment their
bodies don't give off heat and they do
not need to eat drink or breathe if
their bodies are severely damaged the
body part with the greatest mass stays
active and doesn't seem to slow down at
all only one thing actually seems to
impede upon the horrifying persistence
that these cadavers portray in their
attempts to escape
fire the foundation has discovered that
fire may be the one effective way of
stopping the undead specimens but it's
not as easy as simply setting them on
fire high powered fire is needed to
incinerate their tissue and render them
little more than a pile of ash the good
news is there is another method to
neutralize them and that's to weight
them out if the corpse is active but
contained by the foundation's security
they will eventually expire when
whatever power is animating them finally
runs out but this can take between two
days and three weeks which can be
problematic if they're joined by other
friends from the drawers but not all of
the living corpses follow the same
pattern bodies emerge in the drawers
seemingly at random and the state they
arrive in is just as unpredictable this
may correspond to how they died and an
investigation is ongoing in regards to
how these corpses wind up in the morgue
to begin with some arrive in good shape
as if they were recently deceased from a
heart attack or other similar ailment
these are the most dangerous specimens
others may be decomposed or damaged
which will cause them to be slower but
some are in such poor condition that
they can't get up off the slab at all
and that's where scp-022 reacts in an
unexpected way the cadaver may be too
damaged to move but it's still
reanimated and will struggle and twitch
on the slab for whatever the duration is
of their reanimated life but if it
expires while still on the slab the slab
will act on its own and slide back into
the drawer with the cadaver still on it
the body then disappears and from what
witnesses have reported a smell of
burning tissue similar to cremation then
fills the air in the morgue no one knows
where the corpses go but perhaps more
importantly where do they come from that
is the one question that concerns the
foundation the most about scp-022
while the main priority is to contain
the reanimated corpses studying them is
also vital unfortunately testing on the
reanimated is limited due to their
aggressive nature however agents have
been able to observe them just enough to
describe them and send the descriptions
out to law enforcement as evidence shows
that scp-022 may also be able to reach
outside of the confines of the morgue
what the foundation has learned from
interfacing with local law enforcement
is that every single one resembles a
corpse stolen from a morgue around the
country studies of the specimens after
they expire if not consumed by the
drawers is the easiest way to conduct
testing they can be examined safely and
appear to be standard human corpses with
the only exception being any damage done
during the attempt by the foundation to
contain them they don't seem to have any
unusual organs or chemicals in the body
and no explanation for their reanimation
can be found there is however one other
element of
scp-022 that concerns researchers
nothing seems to be able to be added to
the morgue when something is placed into
or enters the room it vanishes after
only seconds this has happened to
inanimate objects as well as to animals
and even to people there is no evidence
as to where these specimens go what
makes this happen is unknown but
provides further evidence for the theory
that there is definitely some dangerous
anomaly governing scp-022
far beyond the fact corpses are simply
reanimating while the rest of the
hospital that contains scp-022 has so
far been free of anomalies and is a
standard abandoned building an
exploration of the room above the morgue
revealed something concerning in the
room agents discovered a massive pile of
matter that seemed to be composed of all
the things that had vanished upon
entering
scp-022 all of the metal objects had
been broken down and the organic
material had decomposed everything
looked like it had been there far longer
than the time since it had vanished
despite appearing only three minutes
after its disappearance and testing but
one thing was missing from the mystery
pile what happened to the people who had
disappeared inside the morgue none of
the humans who disappeared either in
accidents before the foundation stepped
in or in testing appeared in the pile in
decayed form but it wasn't long before
they appeared in another way the
foundation observed that several of the
corpses that appeared from behind the
drawers of scp-022
resembled the unfortunate citizens who
had disappeared into the room in the
past the morgue's victims had returned
and they wanted out now it was clear
that the priority had to be containment
the door to the facility was destroyed
during a security breach by a
particularly tenacious specimen so the
foundation installed a more powerful
vault door shortly after taking over the
facility with orders that it must remain
locked at all times because of the
morgue's ability to absorb anything that
enters it containment of the entities is
dependent entirely on automated systems
if the cadavers happen to make it
through the vault door placed just
outside of the perimeter of the original
scp-022 room awaiting their arrival are
the foundation's high-powered automated
fire weapons once the undead cross the
threshold of the door the weapons are
triggered and incinerate them
immediately it is only if this system
fails that response teams are sent in to
contain the threat followed by cleanup
crews no humans are to enter scp-022
unless further testing is needed nor is
any entity to be removed from the
containment site while the first time
the foundation encountered one of the
reanimated corpses it had been
immediately destroyed the second time
was a different story it appeared to be
an asian man in his 50s and its body was
mostly intact with the exception of a
large chest scar that resembled that of
an autopsy it claimed its name was john
and remembered dying in a car accident
but it refused to admit that it was dead
then it saw its reflection and things
took a disturbing turn while the
specimen had remained calm until then it
became extremely angry as soon as it saw
its image on the steel table and had to
be restrained while in containment it
claimed over and over again that it was
not the man it saw in its reflection
whoever was in the body didn't believe
it was the older asian man
it then became enraged screaming and
smashing its head against a wall until
it stopped talking and eventually
stopped moving all together no more
information could be obtained what was
scp-022 doing to the people who appeared
in it the answer to that question became
a little clearer after the foundation
was able to capture a specimen again
this time it was shortly after a d-class
designated
d-5619 had been sent into the morgue and
immediately disappeared what emerged
from the drawers shortly thereafter
though wasn't the d-class it was a
little girl who looked to be about 12
years old and just like the cadaver
captured prior when restrained it became
extremely angry however it did
eventually cooperate in answering
questions for the foundation it was soon
identified as d 5619
the unfortunate d-class testing victim
it wasn't long after the question of
what had happened to d 5619's body was
answered
three weeks following the incident d
5619's body was returned from the
drawers but it wasn't him inside of it a
brief interview confirmed that this was
a very confused but overall cooperative
89 year old woman in the body of the
d-class whatever effect is going on
within scp-022
it seems to return people in twisted
mismatched combinations of body and mind
the foundation is still investigating
exactly what is happening inside of
scp-022 with a focus on how the anomaly
gets its corpses from around great
britain but when dealing with the
mystery morgue itself the foundation
holds to a simple rule nothing gets in
and nothing gets out for more on a
mysterious thread in an unlikely place
check out
scp-974 treehouse predator or check out
this other video instead for more from
scp explained